[موسيقى]
في نهاية اليوم الأمر كله يتعلق
بإمكانية إحضار المياه النظيفة إلى المدرسة في
كثير من الأحيان عندما لا تحتوي المدرسة على
مياه نظيفة
، يجب إرسال الأطفال إلى المنزل ، لذلك بالنسبة لي ، فإن
المياه النظيفة تغير كل شيء في
المجتمع ،
اسمي ماراندينيما  fomo أنا
مؤسس مياه كاسيني
في جوهانسبرج جنوب إفريقيا ،
تصنع مياه الكازينو أنظمة تنقية المياه
التي تساعد المجتمعات
على الوصول إلى المياه النظيفة ، لذلك
يكمن ابتكارنا في المقام الأول في مجالين رئيسيين
نستخدم قشور جوز المكاديميا من مصادر محلية
من مزارعينا في جنوب إفريقيا
وهذا  هي مادة مستدامة نستخدمها
كجزء من نظام الترشيح الخاص بنا ،
الجزء الثاني منها عبارة عن طاقة متجددة
نأخذ المياه من مصدر باستخدام
الطاقة الشمسية
على مدار العامين الماضيين
، لم يكن الماء في زحف هاموند
آمنًا للشرب
تكنولوجيا المعالجة التي يمكنها إزالة
تلك الملوثات ، لدينا علامات تبويب في جميع
أنحاء المدارس حيث يشرب الجميع
الماء
للحصول على نقطة وصول ثانية مجانية هو ما نسميه
نقيًا  كشك المياه كشك العلاقات العامة هو كشك
يواجه المجتمع
والذي يسمح للمجتمع
نفسه
بالقدوم وإعادة تعبئة علبه ، لدينا
حوالي 50 موقعًا في جنوب إفريقيا ، لذلك
ننتج كل شهر 3 ملايين لتر
من المياه نريد أن نرى المستقبل  حيث
يستطيع كل مجتمع الحصول على المياه
المستدامة الخاصة به